hey youtubers is Charlie so you guys
requested a video on Teen Titans Judas
contract so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet but I'll cover
all the comic book stuff too if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything I do Marvel and DC
every week there's a giveaway going on
I'll explain at the end of the video but
overall Judas contract was a big step up
over the previous DC animated films
Justice League war was a lot of fun but
you have to imagine that this is the
younger generation of the DC Universe so
it's more in continuity with films like
son of Batman which informs some of the
Deathstroke arc which is one of the big
things that I did not like so I'll
explain all the Deathstroke problems but
a lot of it is just a confluence of the
changes they made from the comic books
and pre-existing Canon cuz they hadn't
set up in the animated films so they
kind of had to work with the characters
that they had in the story that they
were already told so if you watched all
the DC animated films they're all in the
same Canon so that means that the next
film after this will have to acknowledge
the events of Judah's contract in the
repercussions so that's like a big
post-credit scene introducing Donna Troy
it's not just about the cool superpowers
Navy uniforms and daring adventures
it's about us helping each other grow be
better people
listen I know you're not supposed to
talk about this but it's got it has
there's a new girl right all I can say
is that she's a wonderful addition come
on our fire would kill me it's
everyone's like yay Donna Troy is part
of the animated universe now it's about
time she joined the team so one of the
really good examples of why they had to
change things in the makeup of the team
is because in the original Judas
contract comic book Donna Troy in cyborg
were already members of Teen Titans
there was no Damian Wayne it was the
first appearance of Nightwing on the
team as Nightwing himself so Nightwing
was a big part of the original story but
obviously because Damian Wayne is such a
big part of the animated movies that
they've been doing so far they had to
find a way to fit those characters both
into the team so nightly in the movie is
coming back after being gone for a long
time but he and Starfire did have a
thing in the comics so when he and Corey
are cozying up to each other in the
movie that is comic book cannon and
Deathstroke is the big villain of the
Judas contract arc
Tara in the movie was actually great
that's Christina Ricci if you didn't
recognize the voice so Wednesday Addams
is playing the betrayer in it's totally
comic-book accurate she probably had the
best arc of all the characters in the
movie in some of you if you haven't read
the comic book there was that creepy
relationship with slave where it's like
she wants to be with him like in an
adult way it's the same thing in the
comic book she's supposed to be like 14
years old in the comic book he's like 45
so if you got that weird affection that
she showed for him in the movie was
creepy it was way more gross in the
comic book there were a few minor
changes they made to her character with
the way they told her origin story the
reason why she was working with Slade
why she felt so loyal to him Slade came
to her rescue and then used her as a
means to an end to get back at the Teen
Titans
but the comic book version of the story
is way less forgiving of her she just
goes crazy insane they make her think
that her parents are being held and
unless she helps them betray the Teen
Titans and inform on them they'll kill
her parents but then later she finds out
her parents had been dead for a long
time so the betrayer herself gets
betrayed but the end of the story where
she tries to find some Redemption and
help them take down brother blood she
brings the ceiling down on herself this
was the way she died in the comic book
but
talk about some of the problems of so
destro one of the best comic book
characters ever miguel ferrer was great
in his performance he's been playing
Deathstroke in the animated movies for a
while now he recently passed away so may
he rest in peace just like all the other
voice actors in the movie their
performance was great but some of the
story arcs were just awful
in the comics the reason he's trying to
take down the Teen Titans is because of
the death of his son grant Wilson now
his son died because of actions that he
took but he still resents the Teen
Titans and blamed them for his death so
you kill my family I won't stop - you're
all in the ground it's a much more
personal connection to the Teen Titans
and you understand his pain his son is
dead
but in the movie the reason he hates the
Teen Titans is because during the Batman
versus Robin movie Damian Wayne stops
him from taking over the League of
Assassins
go ahead finish me you were trained to
kill your enemies weren't you to what
you want it's what I would do
it's what your grandfather would do well
do it no I'm my father's son too
I'm robbing
so if you're a big comic book fan you
know there's a big problem with that
idea
Slade Wilson would never try to join the
League of Assassins he's a loner he's
already as good of a fighter as he's
ever going to be he's way better than
any of the League of Assassins and he
doesn't want a team under him he works
alone so there should be no reason for
him to join the league but because the
movie universe set that up they had to
use that as his motivation during Judas
contract it just felt completely flat
it's like you know what was this a
couple movies ago he wanted to join the
league that doesn't even sound like a
Deathstroke thing so I really did not
like this destro comic book arc he comes
off a little mustache twirly speaking of
which the other big flaw of the movie is
brother Bloods character he winds up
being this paint-by-numbers villain that
just absorbs all of their powers and
becomes this big boss for them to take
down but you really don't understand why
he's doing what he's doing like what's
the point even if you know the comic
books and you understand brother Bloods
character we are way in left-field so
did not like brother blood in the movie
but they did do a good job of setting up
Jericho who is another one of Slade
Wilson's children so we haven't met
ravager yet but Jericho is a big part of
the Judas contract arc this movie though
just used him as a test subject so
whatever they're going to do with him in
the animated movies we'll find out in
the next big adventure but he has
psychic abilities he can astrally
project himself so he does have super
powers like they imply in this so he
sort of heals himself so the big change
here is that they make no mention of the
fact that he's Slade Wilson's son
hopefully they won't change that in the
comic book universe because so far the
animated version of Deathstroke has been
pretty weak compared to his comic book
self if you want to read a really
awesome version of Deathstroke and
you've never read him before start with
rebirth Deathstroke rebirth number one
it's being written by Christopher priest
he's really famous for writing this
badass Black Panther run so he said his
goal of the Deathstroke comic book is to
just infuse a lot more pesos in depth
into the character much more than comics
have done him credit there's a lot of
reasons why he does the things he does
so that's where they tried to establish
during the rebirth comic just to give
you an idea of who he is in what informs
his decisions
so overall Judas contract is a step up
in quality from the last Teen Titans
movie but I
like they could do a much better job
with their villains but the problem is
is they only have about an hour and a
half to tell a story so if you have all
these heroes they're just not as much
time to fill out the villain characters
so we'll see how they do it but I have a
feeling that the next movie will focus
on setting up the Donna Troy character
so it'll be a Donna Troy centric story
but let me know what did you guys think
of the Judas contract and there's a new
round of the blasts ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's winner J
Watson please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so while you wait for my
next video click here for a thor
ragnarok and click here for brand new
splash in justice - thank you so much
for watching let's high-five I'll see
you guys in the next video